biden appears to be out of step with the
american people after saying this
i didn't over promise
and but i have probably uh
outperformed what anybody thought would
happen
and that's not a good sign for the
president here's this only 28 percent of
americans say they want him to run for
re-election in 2024 including just 48
percent of democrats and jesse there was
another poll today the eight people
uh 28 of people saying they thought the
country was on the right track and i it
crossed my mind that maybe those are the
same 28 percent
say you're in a relationship with a
woman for a year dana well not you
okay but yeah let's just say the guys
are in a relationship and you know the
relationship is not going well okay do
you say on the one year anniversary
honey i have outperformed expectations
i mean maybe you have if the
expectations were really low but we have
high expectations for the president of
the united states it's not like we
elected larry from the back office
that's like shy and gets crumbs all over
his jacket when he eats his cinnabon i
mean if larry was president and he had
the year by i say larry you know what
you outperformed but this is joe biden
who allegedly got more votes than any
other person in american history right
this is the guy that's crying what do
you say he's gonna crush the virus
it's like imagine you're an olympic
diver dana and you walk on the board and
you announce that you are going to do a
reverse three and a half with a half
twist degree of difficulty 4.1 and then
you get up and you do a can opener
and you pull yourself out of the water
and you demand a gold medal that's joe
biden he's he has screwed up the
management of expectations watch the
execution you are really challenging my
imagination i have to say geraldo
the president truly believes that he did
not sell his accomplishments well enough
to the american people he's going to he
says he's going to get out there and do
a lot more of that will that help
i i doubt that that will help although
you can't take weekends long weekends
when you're president of the united
states you can't spend a quarter of your
time in delaware as beautiful as it is
on the beach there but there are two
things that i think he did not do well
enough he should have taken more credit
about the bipartisan infrastructure bill
which was a big deal and it is going to
affect every single congressional
district and the other thing is he did
get that massive coveted relief
uh passed he shepherded that through in
the early days of his presidency it's
like his first six months was one story
and his last six months is the is the
other story the kd reference you know he
has no wins to to uh to uh you know
check back uh on and he's out of energy
it just seems that there's no operation
warp speed there's no sense of urgency
there's no come on let's go he should be
the guy
making those uh kids in the white house
jump through hoops you made me think
he's lost uh he's lost that you made me
think if there was a first six months in
the second six months greg what's the
next six months look like
i don't know but you know dana imagine
you're an olympic diver and you and your
girlfriend
are renting a car
for nine dollars a day you're gonna rent
a car from budget for nine dollars a day
what does that do to your expectations
it lowers them so joe is right when he
says he outperforms his expectations
because they were so damn low geraldo
was grateful 20 minutes ago that the guy
was standing so all everybody expected
from joe was like no tweeting like the
old boss please don't bomb texas after
you drank too much nyquil no one no one
has ever been elected with such low
expectations yet at the same time he
failed the low expectations because the
science of human relations shows that
the more you know someone the worse they
are so when he was in the basement
chained to a rusty solo flex we didn't
think he was so bad but then as he
started climbing up the stairs and
walking around the more you saw them the
less you thought of him so he's really
the first
candidate that that they were right
remember we talked about it the less you
see the better he does maybe that was
the best strategy
right katie last word to you
well i was not an olympic diver but i
was an actual diver so i understand what
jesse's trying to say there with his
analogy uh
so biden insisted yesterday that he's
not a socialist but he is certainly a
proxy for bernie sanders who is in
charge of the senate budget committee
and he's tried and failed to govern as a
socialist with these multi-trillion
dollar bills especially build back
better which failed the other thing
yesterday when he said that he's going
to be campaigning a lot
i bet republicans love that and i think
that democrats are going to say they
have lots of scheduling conflicts
especially
tough positions
like stacey abrams lots of scheduling
conflicts lots of appointments when the
president wants to come and campaign for
them when he's sitting at 30
approval so i don't think that the dnc
will really like that strategy in some
ways you think that they can only go up
from here but we'll see there's still a
little room
possibly could be a lower floor all
right congratulations dana on finally
coming out i think that's very brave
jesse took a lot yes i know oops sorry
jessie uh we'll get a mom text i think
okay and